last night David blue appeared on a
podcast and it was very very interesting
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
the shuttlepod podcast is one of those
newer podcasters appeared recently and
it is really really good this podcast is
led by Connor trinia who played Tripp in
um Star Trek Enterprise with his mate
Dominic Keating who played Malcolm Reed
but if you actually remember Connor
trinia also has connections to Stargate
he was in Stargate Origins never seen
that I really probably should
um he played Dr Langford and in SGA he
played Michael there's a link in the
description to the full video now I
listen to the whole thing and I have to
say that David blue is a brilliant
speaker he is really passionate about
what he's talking about and he obviously
loves his work he is a writer director
producer Creator as well as a brilliant
actor and some of the insights he was
able to give us were really really
fascinating one of the things he was
talking about was how Brad Wright would
be watching him changes like we were
doing the table read of the first
episode in the Atlantis gate room in the
shadow of the Atlantis gate which was
kind of cool for a nerd and I looked
over and Brad and Rob were like really
staring at us as we were reading and at
the end because I'm a producer director
writer as well I was like just out of
curiosity what was that
and uh and he's like we were seeing how
you talk we were seeing how you all are
so we could start bringing that into the
character oh so cool and they very much
somewhat did like the character wasn't
me but there were parts of me in him uh
in Eli but at the same time it's funny
how some things started to go away that
I ended up having like in season two I
think I went up to Carl Carl binder and
said hey I don't quote movies anymore
I love that I did that yeah and he's
like yeah you're right he's like I'm
trying to stop doing that didn't we I'm
like can I add this yeah and then and he
let me add one in the next episode
was really good in the beginning oh that
was them that was them being awesome
this is something I've heard about Brad
Wright a few times that he really liked
getting to know the actors and then
bringing through some of their
mannerisms some of the character
themselves into the characters they were
playing his feeling was I believe that
it made the characters more genuine now
we know this happened with Richard Dean
Anderson Richard D Hanson basically said
look I want to play O'Neill two else but
I want to have some of my humor and some
of my personality brought through he
basically said he wouldn't do it
otherwise and it was because of Richard
Dean Anderson standing firm on that that
really sg1 got the character of a show
that it did would we have got quite so
much humor if it wasn't for Richard Dean
Anderson's demand but Brad writes
willingness to go with it and to go
further that he developed all of the
characters around the personality and
the Persona of the actors at least to a
degree now David blue talks about that
in such a loving way and he actually
obviously really looked up to Brad
Wright at any time we get to see a
little bit more behind the cameras like
this I think it's fascinating to learn
David blue did very briefly mention the
unmade Stargate movie that was planned
he said he got to learn loads about how
sg1 SGA and SGU are going to be brought
together in this movie I think he was
talking about Revolution that would have
been a straight to DVD movie following
Stargate Continuum it really is a shame
we didn't get to see these strange DVD
movies but
you know DVDs just sort of died at the
wrong time I really wish MGM had got a
deal with Netflix at that time it would
have been genius but they were going
through some financial problems
themselves
financial problems actually David blue
did talk about he talks about how
Universe got canceled now he did mention
the controversy now you guys know that
if your regular side trackers
I never loved Stargate Universe or at
very least it's not in my heart like
Stargate SG-1 and Stargate Atlantis are
and then Atlantis was the more I I would
say fun adventury version yeah and then
then there's a controversy to it but
then Universe was the gritty realistic
totally it was much much different yeah
which I loved and honestly I don't think
anybody would have done it if it wasn't
different like I said I didn't want to
do more of the same it was I would like
their Stark SGU had uh an intensity to
it like
um I felt that it was too serious I felt
that the tone just changed too much and
that really I found it a little boring
at times but the people that love SGU
adore it and I have full respect for you
guys I've actually met people that love
SGU and don't like sg1 now that just
confuses me but then today we're talking
about opinion here and opinion matters
and David blue obviously loved what he
was doing but he even actually mentioned
it he doesn't think a lot of the actors
that were in Stargate Universe would
have done the show if it was going to be
the same as sg1 and SGA but more
importantly it gave us even more insight
to Brad Wright and why Brad Wright felt
the SGU needed to be so different
um Brad Wright actually said it best he
said because I asked him you have to
understand I'm I love entertainment I've
seen everything huge Quantum Leap fan
you know loved Star Trek I've watched
everything
Eli and I have that in common
um but I'm very curious as a writer as a
producer as a director as a Creator as
well so I probably bothered the hell out
of them asking questions and one of the
things I asked was why did you do this
show this was early on when I thought I
had the right to ask things yeah yeah he
said he had any reason were you working
for the man don't ask me you get one
yeah
um but I said you know why'd you do this
and he very intelligently explained he's
like by the time we were done with sg1
there wasn't risk anymore they were Gods
yeah literally some of them right and I
wanted to explore risk again what if
they don't always win yeah and I as a
Creator and as a fan love that you know
I love slow Burns I love you don't know
how it's gonna end in surprises and all
of that so they but the ability to do
that I any of us would have signed on in
a heartbeat he was obviously asked about
the Revival now he mentioned Roland
emerick's plans to completely erase all
of what happened before sg1 SGU SGA he
was going to do his Trilogy a hard
reboot like none of the TV Brilliance
ever happened
David blue says thank God Roland Emrick
didn't get to do that but he has heard a
lot of information coming out of MGM
talking to his friends people in and
around the industry like I do about
what's going on but uh I know a lot of
the people as I'm sure you guys do so I
hear some of the pictures some of where
it's at now nothing he said would be a
surprise to any side tracker he
basically said look they're looking to
do in lots of different things he looks
like he's going to be a reboot a
continuation maybe various other things
that maybe they're going to go this way
or go that way and some of the stuff
sounds cool some of it don't I will say
this I hope that whatever they do honors
what came before it sounds like he's
heard about lots of the pitches that
have gone on I need like some ideas he
doesn't like others I'm hoping he means
he doesn't like the Bad Robot
suggestions which we've told you about
on this channel but he loves some of the
ones coming from maybe like Mark Fergus
Etc again that we told you first
exclusively on Sidetrack the way he
actually then spoke about the lots of
different things they're planning do
with the Stargate franchise was like
music to my ears though because again
this is a little bit more confirmation
of what I've been talking about for over
a year a couple of years gone by but the
Amazon have always sort of seen Stargate
as a tentpole project something that
they would could really build a
franchise around that we would get to
see multiple Seasons running together
some might be set in different time
frames you could even get to see like we
suggested an ancients TV series or a
Jaffa TV series or something like this
stories a little bit like Star Wars or
Marvel where you've got movies and TV
series that influence each other that
work together
um but that actually tell the story from
lots of different directions now I'm
reading a lot between the lines there
from what David blue actually said but
it does seem that it adds a little bit
more concrete to rumors that I've been
hearing for quite a long time another
thing he said that really did music to
my ears again was that he has spoken to
almost all of the actors and almost all
of them want to return to Stargate any
actor would of course come back I will
tell you having talked to them every
actor on SGU that I've spoken to would
come back in a heartbeat every actor
from sg1 and Atlantis for the most part
would come back in a heartbeat and we're
like yeah I'd love to play in this world
more and the more the merrier not just a
one-off I'd like to be in the past you
know because we enjoy eating and paying
bills now we have told you about rumors
about Robert Carlisle of potentially
being sort of semi-approached he's
actually been talking to lots of
interviews at the moment because his new
Monty uh full Montessori TV series comes
out next week
um and he's actually said that yeah he
would return to SGU he mentioned how
look we're all Frozen still floating
iron up there we could return if
somebody wants us to now I know through
my sources that there's been very
informal conversations to Robert
Carlisle about whether he would be able
to return and I told you at the time six
months ago that he said oh yes David
blue and Robert Carlisle confirm that
that's true
I've also told you that Michael Shanks
and Amanda Tapping have been approached
and again
we know that's true anyway without David
blue I would love David blue to get
approached but I don't believe he has
been and actually I was told a few
months ago that he hasn't so this again
really I think emphasizes that point
that David blue hasn't been approached
yet the biggest thing though that David
blue pointed out is that if we want
Stargate to return we need to keep
hammering at home to Amazon that we want
this damn show and help cultivate the
desire look at Star Trek you know would
there be uh strange new worlds Discovery
and Picard if there wasn't still a
demand for more stories in that Universe
we need to do the same now I get munged
occasionally that I put out videos about
Stargate too often then I put out all
the different rumors I hear and
sometimes people say look I'm just
getting sick of listening to it but at
the end of the day I'm talking about a
TV show that I adore and that I
desperately want to return I share the
honest rumors I hear from people that I
have checked and vetted that working
around the industry and I share them
with you as quickly as I possibly can we
need to do things like sign the petition
that I've set up asking Amazon to
consider getting in touch with Brad
right there's a link in the description
to it please go and sign it we need to
like share these videos but also don't
just advertise Sidetrack even though it
helps me if you do get out there go on
Twitter use the bring back Stargate
hashtag just
share videos or comments about Stargate
we need to get them metadata they call
it Amazon need to see that we are
interested because if we're interested
they'll make the show and maybe they'll
make the show that we actually want now
he actually did warn us as well not to
eat ourselves from the inside out now I
think he meant from that that we really
need to avoid a lot of the negativity
that we've seen we need to avoid the
hate clickers there are channels and
YouTube channels out there that all they
do is focus on the negativity and they
know that people quite like it look at
the end of the day if you watch the news
anytime for last 30 years
bad new cells good news really doesn't
make it and YouTubers some have found
that that works for them and they will
hate a TV show before it even comes out
just because they know that if they
shout it's going to be woke a load of
people will click on that video whatever
you thought of rings of power and I
found it a little boring
I will say that there was a lots and
lots of negativity out there from
YouTubers that hadn't seen it they were
seeing little Snippets of information
and they were screaming it was going to
be a woke pile of garbage none of these
people that's in the show at that point
so all I would say is that let's avoid
that
let's not eat ourselves from the inside
out let's not jump on the bandwagon
negativity if you've seen videos like
that ignore them wait until the show
comes out yourself and anyway you can
get all of your news on Stargate from
here so you know why would you go
anywhere else yeah oh go over to the
shuttle pod podcast
give the video a view give them a
subscribe it's a really brilliant
Channel I subscribed a couple of months
ago there's been some fascinating
conversations on there particularly if
you're Trekkie but if you're a Sci-Fi
fan in general don't forget there's a
link in the description to the video but
guys I'd love to know what you think as
always is there anything else that David
blue talked about in this that I really
should have spoken about and would you
like to see him return as Eli in a
future series personally oh yeah against
the comments to tell me exactly what
you're thinking if you are new to the
Channel please don't forget to like
subscribe uh you know what to do and
don't forget to hit the Bell
notification so you never miss any of
our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos air first
and you get to see them premiered
without any of the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]